how's it going everybody about a week
ago we received new leaked photos for
Avengers for the photos were really
awesome and they gave us a different
look at some of the characters like
Ronan and we also saw some photos of
characters that were blurred out and
pixelated a little bit and I actually
think that in some of these blurred
photos of Thanos we find out a little
bit about Avengers 4 if you haven't seen
these photos or my video yet you can
check it out in the link above also my
giveaway still continues if you'd like a
chance to win a copy of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray special edition
posters and some special memorabilia all
you have to do is subscribe like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero ok
so let's take a look at these blurred
photos of Thanos the first thing that I
notice in these pictures is that he's
wearing his armor the armor is something
we didn't really see much of an Avengers
4 we only saw it in the very beginning
of Avengers infinity war when Hulk tried
to take on Thanos and lost then he takes
it off and doesn't wear it again for the
rest of the movie also looking at these
photos it looks like he has not only one
but two swords the sword was something
that we thought we would see an infinity
war but never saw it
there was a toy that came out before
Infinity Ward that had Thanos holding
his sword but again we never saw it so
in these pictures we have Thanos with
his armor on holding two swords why if
he didn't really use it in infinity war
why would he use it in Avengers 4 so
real quick let's talk about why he
probably was wearing his armor in the
beginning of Avengers infinity war so
Fanus only had one Infinity stone when
he came across Thor ship and it was by
no mistake that he found them he knows
where all of the Infinity stones are he
knows that the tesseract was with them
on that ship he knew that the Power
Stone was on Xandar that's why he went
to Xander before he went and got the
space stone he knew that the reality
stone was with the collector he knew
that gomorrah knew where the soul stone
was and he also knew that the time stone
and the mind stone were on earth let's
not forget that Thanos is a genius and
he's a master at combat and strategy so
he's done his research he knows where
the stones are and he knows who they're
with so he knew that the space stone was
with Thor Loki and other as guardians
and he knows that Thor and as guardians
in general are very strong beans so he
put on his armor because he knew that he
would have to fight and although he had
the power stone he still knows how
strong Thor and as Guardians are so he
put on his armor but once he gets to
Infinity stones he takes off his armor
knowing that the power of two Infinity
stones can pretty much defeat anything
that he'd come against and you can see
this when I Bini MA
presents him the tesseract Thanos takes
off his armor before grabbing it he's
got two Infinity stones now he has the
power of them doesn't need to physically
fight anymore especially since he's only
going to go on to get more so no more
armor we don't see it for the rest of
the movie so I go back to my question
widest anos need armor in Avengers 4
well as I just mentioned
Thanos puts on armor when he knows he'll
have to fight that's what it's for
it's battle armor so why does Stannis
need battle armor if he has the Infinity
Gauntlet well I actually don't see the
gauntlet in any of these photos and I
personally think it's because in
Avengers 4 Thanos won't be able to use
the Infinity Gauntlet anymore the Russo
brothers have stated that Thanos and the
Infinity Gauntlet are permanently
damaged from the snap and that using all
the stones at once cost Thanos I think
it cost him the gauntlet and not only
that but it also left him in a weakened
state to where he probably isn't strong
enough to wield the power of all the
stones at once anymore he can probably
use the stones individually because
after the snap he uses the space stone
to get away from Thor but as far as
using the gauntlet for battle now I
think that's off the table cuz as you
can see in the end of Infinity Ward it's
pretty messed up and again the Rissa
brother said that it's permanently
damaged and they also said that Avengers
4 is going to be nothing like what we
think it's going to be and I think we
all think it's going to involve the
Infinity Gauntlet but what if it doesn't
we know that the Infinity Gauntlet is
damaged you can clearly see that the
Russo brothers said it's permanently
damaged we have Captain Marvel coming in
who is apparently the strongest in the
MCU perhaps somehow he loses the
Infinity Gauntlet and the stones there's
a number of ways that he could lose the
Infinity Gauntlet or the stones but
whatever the reason may be it does seem
like he's going to be fighting in
Avengers 4 without the Infinity Gauntlet
and that's why I think he's wearing his
armor and wielding two swords in these
photos but what do you all think about
my theory do you think that vanos is
going to go into battle without the
Infinity Gauntlet and Infinity stones in
Avengers 4 or do you think that he'll
still be using the gauntlet let me know
what you all think in the comments below
don't forget to subscribe like and
comment to enter the giveaway and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]